[Musique]
des côtes paisibles à des milliers de
kilomètres de l'Ukraine et de la Russie
mais ce petit comté irlandais au drapeau
bleu et jaune semblait destiné à jouer
un rôle dans le conflit au cours des
derniers mois c'est ici que Ghana est
des centaines d'autres ukrainiens ont
trouvé refuge différent
tout est différent Lancel en quelques
mois la petite ville de Lisbonne à 800
habitants a vu sa population doublée des
centaines de réfugiés sont maintenant
hébergés dans des hôtels des nouveaux
résidents à qui plusieurs villages de la
région ont ouvert leurs portes malgré
des ressources déjà très limitées il y a
un centre médical
avec de 100 personnes d'habitude et
maintenant
de son personne de plus à soigner oui ça
m'était beaucoup de pression sur nos
services de transport de tout mais je
crois que les gens du village ont ouvert
leur cœur vraiment et maintenant un an
plus tard nous recevons plus de soutien
du gouvernement c'est sûr mais pas
encore assez pour ces services de base
les écoles ont aussi du s'ajuster
il y a eu des problèmes d'espace
explique-t-il puis il a fallu créer
cette classe destinée aux élèves
Ukrainiens comme tous ne parlent pas
bien anglais l'enseignante Oxana
elle-même réfugiée a été embauché pour
les appuyer
c'est gratifiant de pouvoir les aider
dans cet état
nous les comprenons 10 conseillers
municipal le rappelle que pendant des
décennies ce sont les Irlandais qui
quittaient ces côtes pour trouver refuge
ailleurs n'empêche dans cette région
touristique le dilemme est grand entre
la volonté d'accueillir les réfugiés et
l'arrivée prochaine de visiteurs venus
du monde entier
les affiches annonçants des maisons à
vendre comme celle-ci ne sont pas si
facile à trouver en Irlande pays
confronté à une crise du logement depuis
des années la pénurie est
particulièrement importante dans le
marché locatif et touche l'ensemble du
pays et surtout la capitale du blé
début février seul 500 logements étaient
disponible dans cette région urbaine
d'un million 300.000 habitants difficile
pour un nouvel arrivant de se trouver un
toit d'autant que certains centres
d'accueil pour les réfugiés ukrainiens
et demandeurs d'asile venant d'autres
régions du monde sont débordés les
Irlandais ont donc trouvé une autre
solution
environ 500 familles dont celle de
Nathalie Anne Léonard participait au
programme helping Irish host
cette organisation bénévole gère
l'hébergement de réfugiés dans des
résidences privées avec mon mari on
s'est assis et on a décidé ensemble
qu'il fallait absolument qu'on accueille
une famille on pouvait pas laisser les
gens pas avoir de logement on avait la
place on avait envie de le faire donc
depuis plusieurs mois Léna et ses fils
Micha et Pacha partage donc leur
quotidien avec la famille de Nathalie
Yann Léonard une cohabitation dont
personne ne sait combien de temps elle
va durer n'avait rien en commun et
pourtant quand lena est arrivé ici
c'était comme si je découvrais une autre
sœur elle a la même façon de faire avec
ses enfants les enfants jouent ensemble
au quotidien des amitiés qui aident
Micha et Pacha à traverser cette longue
épreuve cela fait plus d'un an qu'ils
n'ont pas vu des proches restaient à
Kiev madame
comme ailleurs au pays cette dernière
année a été marquée par d'importants
défis mais aussi par des liens tissés au
quotidien yes comme d'autres Ukrainiens
Ghana a travaillé dans cette entreprise
qui produit du saumon fumé
en gagnant explique les propriétaires
qui croient qu'en cestallant
définitivement certains Ukrainiens
pourraient contribuer à une économie
affectée par des pénuries de main
d'oeuvre mais Ghana qui a pourtant aimé
son expérience dans ce commerce n'a
qu'une idée en tête
[Musique]
autant son pays d'accueil il a marqué
elle rêve de retrouver sa terre natale
une fois la guerre terminée
si rappelle vous fier Radio-Canada allez
je donne en Irlande